[Applause]
why do i laugh like a sexual predator
i like the way that a sexual predator
sounds better in your accent than any
other
a sexual predator i i don't know why i
laugh like that it's one of life's
mysteries
in the same way as why you dressed as a
gay lumberjack
we may never know i know i like the way
spanish sounds when south american
people are speaking it
i like the way it's i don't understand
it but at least the words are clear to
me you know what i mean when i hear them
speaking i know when a sentence begins
and i know when it ends and you could
tell by the tone whether it was a
question or a statement
you know there's languages you don't
know like
chinese when you're somebody speaking
cantonese you don't know whether it was
a sentence
a paragraph a statement
where the chinese people at tonight i
see an asian there you are
you know what i'm talking about in
cantonese sometimes they don't even
start the the sentences
at the right volume it's not like they
go
sometimes they turn the volume like up
as they're speaking and i mean like
[Applause]
cantonese is a fun language but it's a
hard one to learn when i was in hong
kong
i learned the dumbest words when i was
in hong kong i learned how to say snot
basie and the only reason i think i knew
that was because
i think because i have a big nose and i
was in hong kong and nobody has a big
nose there but that when i kept hearing
basie when i'd walked past people i'm
sure they were going
look at this knows much about a basic
that's what i'm sure they were
translating
and then
hard language to learn though do you
speak cantonese oh dude yeah
what's your name sorry v
just the letter v
then vinnie a vi
oh i'm sorry his name really is v
but he spells it out so it's different
what's your last name
vagina
playhouse this is vagina
sorry about being earlier
accents and so on how people are you can
hear each other from miles away you know
it's very easy to recognize your own
kind really um
some of them some of the voices are very
hard to relax around you know like
cockney i've always found a bit tough
even because even if somebody says
something nice like join a camper cam
morty
you think you're gonna die you know
the the one that's the hardest actually
is the estuary voice
what they call the estuary voice which
is a sort of london orbit orbital
towards
essex and going east i think and it's a
very
uh strange one it's very boneless you
know it's
everything everybody says sounds like
they're saying no i don't think i'll
have that one i think i'll have the
other one it's a little bit
milder
you know there's a few hit them they
splat and
but with with when english people go
away they recognize one another very
easily you know they go to france or
spain or italy and blend into the
environment you'd never know they were
there
they sit there enjoying the atmosphere
talking to the waiters saying what do
you mean it's not [ __ ] chips
i'll come here on a plane you can't
i've got children here what am i
supposed to do with this [ __ ] tomato
fiasco what is that
you they go [ __ ]
we're leaving and americans find it very
easy to recognize one another
because the voice does tend to carry if
you think about it you've never had to
say to an american i'm sorry what was
that come again
but with irish people there is a thing
there is a phenomenon and you see this
all around the world you can go anywhere
go to los angeles or seoul or
tokyo or minsk anywhere
you see irish guys and you know they're
irish because of a phenomenon
called irish hair and it looks like this
how's it going
you've been here long have you i've been
here for 40 years
i'm safe enough to go home i can't quite
seem to guess together i don't know why
do you want a drink doing a ham sandwich
everyone in my pocket
so i appreciate a good culture i
appreciate a good accent you got the
right accent you can get away with a lot
of [ __ ]
you be in a club and say something foul
to a woman in an american accent she
might slap the [ __ ] out of you
like excuse me baby i don't mean to
bother you but you got a fat ass
i love to take you home [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out you [ __ ]
english accent that just roll off the
tongue different excuse me i don't mean
to bother you
but i really love to take you back to my
hotel [ __ ] you doggy stuff a little bit
you know i mean
[ __ ] where you from
oh my god something else
ladies you're laughing some of the
fellows might try that on the way home
did you have a good time with the comedy
show tonight is it really
the next light because you can be a
little bit ahead just a little bit
i don't want much i just want you to
polish me now you know i'm like
i ain't even gonna lie i'll use that
[ __ ] to get some [ __ ] i walk up to a
woman and say anything
excuse me you know what time it is oh my
god your accent is beautiful where are
you from i just make [ __ ] up mcdonald's
england have you ever heard of it
i live right over egg mcmuffin lane have
you ever had
oh my god girl you live my bag make
muffins
i tell you what accent is not sexy is
that east indian accent that's 7-eleven
[ __ ] that turban [ __ ]
that dot towel [ __ ] ladies trust me you
do not want that on top of you on a
saturday night
i'm going to give it to you i know you
wanted you dirty [ __ ] and i
wanted i'm going to give you my pakasani
beef you [ __ ]
say my name say puma sanji pumasanji
[Music]
read this article the top 10 sexiest
accents in the world
number one does anyone know what it was
boston
new zealand yes new zealand does anyone
think this is a sexy accent
new zealand not me i'm not new zealand
guys so new zealand i want to have sex
with you bro like i don't think that's a
very
like six six are we having sex six times
or six six times i don't know
the second one was uh south africa south
africa
do we think do you think south african
accent is sexy
okay a couple of woos come over here i
don't know for me south africa feels
like new zealand accent but like they've
just taken a [ __ ] load of ketamine
basically that's
what i think when i knew the south
african accent number three was irish
yeah do we do we like the irish accent
yeah
i dated an irish guy for a while but he
would never stop talking
an irish back like even when it came to
the bedroom you'd be talking in the bed
he's like oh that was granddad it's good
kraken isn't it i was like what the [ __ ]
is happening
shut the [ __ ] up number four
on the world's sexiest list was italian
no okay just me the thing is italian
accent isn't sexy like if they speak in
italian right because i can say anything
to you in italian and you're like oh my
gosh
but when they speak with their english
athlete and they speak in english with
their italian
accent
that'll make you feel like you're in a
70s porn film guys
could you be like elena elena you like
it in your [ __ ] yeah
from dinner coming up the policy
no they're hilarious funny people but
you got to give it up to them because
they're patriotic
they're patriotic people those sons of
[ __ ] you'll never catch a red redneck
at like an anti-war protest going hell
no we will go
they're just like wait i get to kill
people
and i ain't going to jail
[Music]
wait a minute are they foreigners oh my
god hey dale come on
you're gonna miss it hurry up we'll
hurry up
[Music]
christmas in september
i never do this [ __ ] when i go down
south i never do this material
[ __ ] you talking about boys
no i'm actually going to admit i'm i'm
afraid of those people
no i i really am not like you know all
southern a lot of people that's
those backwoods dudes they're just scary
i always try to like make conversation
with them when i do shows and you know
it's always they got like anger
they're crazy like they love their truck
so you know they got like they're kind
of like they're like angry and proud
so i'm trying to make conversation
because i'm nervous like hey yeah that's
a nice truck guy what kind of truck is
it
it's [ __ ] american truck
it's made in america by a [ __ ]
american
like all right buddy relax no i buy
american [ __ ]
i get a cheeseburger i get american
cheese on that [ __ ]
all right none of that swiss [ __ ] i
don't trust it
it's got all them holes in it people
looking at you